pas de foire à la brocante cette année à
guyancourt l'événement devait se
dérouler ce dimanche 18 septembre place
du marché il a été annulé en amont pour
des raisons de sécurité et de budget
même sort pour le vide greniers de la
mjc aux clayes-sous-bois prévu
initialement le dimanche 2 octobre
il n'aura pas lieu en raison des
difficultés à sécuriser l'ensemble du
périmètre de cette brocante à voisins le
bretonneux aucun événement supprimés
mais la décision n'appartient pas
seulement aux communes elles doivent
suivre des directives de la préfecture
on est en train de prendre chaque
événement à venir déjà jusqu'au mois de
décembre pour vérifier lesquels on
maintient et peut-être si on a supprimé
la suppression des pans de la
sécurisation que nous sommes en mesure
d'apporter et la préfecture nous demande
de remplir un dossier à chaque
manifestation avec le plan vigipirate
les mesures de sécurité ont été augmenté
par rapport aux éditions précédentes
la vigilance doit redoubler notamment
sur les grands rassemblements ont
renforcé les mesures de sécurité
jusque là on essaie de tout garder parce
que en accord avec la police on les fait
dans des lieux fermés
pas de quoi s'alarmer dans les faits la
majorité des communes de saint quentin
en yvelines n'a pas été impactée pour
l'instant d'autres communes qui
ressentent leur événement dans des
espaces fermés
voilà mais tout cela ça concerne que 10
20 % des communes
la grande majorité des communes n'ont
pas changé leurs événements des
décisions au cas par cas qui ne devrait
pas trop venir perturber le calendrier
événementiel du territoire aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas d'événements organisés par
l'agglomération qui était adulé et
d'ailleurs nous sommes en train de
travailler avec les services de la
préfecture pour l'organisation des
championnats d'europe de cyclisme sur
piste et cette compétition aura bien
lieu à saint quentin en yvelines seul
territoire de comptines et d'autres
manifestations sont à l'étude notamment
les courses de plein air difficile à
sécuriser la 16e édition de la route des
quatre châteaux en vallée de chevreuse
en novembre est d'ores et déjà annulé
pour des raisons de sécurité